MODERATOR: All right.
And thank you all
for joining us today.
We have a Talks at Google event
for you that's really special,
and is cool, cool, cool.
We're here to celebrate
the fifth season
of the NBC show "Community."
We're about in halfway
through the run right now.
We picked it up
after the Olympics
and we're ready to
sprint to the end.
So it is our true honor today
to have on co-showrunner Chris
McKenna.
Who do we have?
We have Danny Pudi, Abed Nadir,
Alison Brie, Annie Edison,
and it's dean-irific Jim Rash.
All right, so I have a
few questions of my own.
We'll have some questions
from the audience as well.
And we actually recruited some
questions from human beings
across the United States.
So we'll go from them as well.
So to bring
everybody up to speed
we got season five this season.
Harmon's back.
McKenna's back.
You filled all
Hall-H at Comic-Con.
It was pretty amazing.
So congrats on that.
What were the early
days of shooting like?
Was it business as
usual, or something
completely different,
new sense of purpose?
CHRIS: How'd you guys feel?
ALISON: I felt like everything
felt back to normal.
Whereas there may
or may not have
been a season where things
didn't feel as normal.
DANNY: Gas leak?
ALISON: And then
suddenly it was like ah,
putting on that pair
of your favorite jeans.
JIM: It was.
ALISON: I don't know.
I always have trouble
finding good jeans.
JIM: Yeah, no.
ALISON: That was not a good.
JIM: Clearly.
No, your analogy works.
Feels like an old pair of jeans.
ALISON: That old pair of
jeans that still fits.
DANNY: Good old Wranglers.
All those Cavariccis.
CHRIS: That haven't been
washed in at least 10 weeks
of preproduction.
ALISON: Definitely.
Definitely not.
DANNY: They're funny though.
Very funny jeans.
CHRIS: Do you sleep
in them on the couch?
JIM: Yeah.
ALISON: They small but
it's a familiar smell.
It's a good smell.
CHRIS: Well good.
JIM: So the answer is yes.
DANNY: Yes.
Jean comfortable.
I think it's comfortable.
I think it felt good.
I think as soon as we
had the first table
read we just felt like
oh, it was-- This is good.
And it's also for
us too like we never
thought we'd have
a fifth season.
So I mean to actually
have a fifth season be
like re-excited about
it was really cool.
ALISON: I feel like
more than any other year
this year everyone felt relaxed.
That's never been the case.
The first year it's like
everyone's super excited,
because you're doing a show,
and then the second year it's
like, oh my god,
we made it back,
and then the third year
was very tumultuous.
You know, we've had such an up
and down ride the whole time,
and finally this
year I think, one,
with us just having
peace of mind of like,
well anything could
happen and it's fine.
CHRIS: Yeah.
ALISON: You know?
CHRIS: You have to
because, you know
we were taken off the schedules.
There has always been
an ax hanging over
"Community"'s head.
And in season three it
seemed to have come down
where we were taken
off the schedule.
So we were just making episodes.
We didn't think they
were ever going to air.
ALISON: Just black
hole of episodes.
CHRIS: And yeah, some of us
may have fell into the abyss.
And it was probably
reflected in a lot
of the-- Stuff got
really dark that year.
I love that season,
but we definitely
plumbed some dark
depths by the end.
And then what do you know,
we came back on in March.
And because guess what?
8 o'clock.
That's a tough time period.
Other shows, you know,
get beaten up there too.
And so we were put
back to be pummeled on
by "Big Bang Theory,"
and we're still here.
MODERATOR: That's cool.
Was it difficult
to transition back
after being gone for a season
from my writing and showrunning
perspective Chris?
CHRIS: It was exciting.
I would say, Harmon and I were
really excited to go back.
We were really invigorated.
We just wanted to get back to
basics with the characters,
and we were so happy there
were no curve-balls thrown
our way like, you
know, main actors
deciding that they were
going to leave the show.
We were very excited, and
that disappeared very quickly.
But unlike season three where
we were about to commit suicide,
as Alison said, you
just kinda go, look--
ALISON: We've been
through so much.
CHRIS: We've been
Maybe we were just numb to
it, like an abused child.
We were just like, OK,
we'll deal with it.
It was sad, but
we dealt with it.
And I think I don't know.
How do you guys
feel that we dealt
with what we had
to contend with?
ALISON: I like "Community"
addresses a lot of things.
I feel like we just go after
them and then get rid of them.
That sounded very bad.
DANNY: Yeah it did.
ALISON: But it's sort of
like rather than things that
are going to hang on
for long periods of time
where people thought
cast members are leaving,
are they going to stretch it
out over the whole season,
is it going to feel
like a weird thing,
it's like no, let's
just address-- We
all know he's leaving.
The audience knows he's leaving.
Let's just address
that, talk about it.
He's going to leave and then
life is going to go on after.
CHRIS: We'll find someone else
ALISON: Yeah.
We've moved on.
CHRIS: Better and
smarter, and funnier.
John Oliver.
Jonathon Banks.
No, so because there was
the idea of like, oh, do you
want to spread that out?
You know, if we
only get five do you
want to spread that
over the full season?
I'm like, ugh, that's
just like having
your boyfriend is
broken up with you.
ALISON: But he's still
living in your apartment.
CHRIS: Hanging out, and
you know, occasionally
like stopping by in the
middle of the night, and no.
JIM: Which it'd also be
that weird thing where
you're justifying
why he's not there.
ALISON: Yeah.
JIM: He's on that trip.
CHRIS: Yeah.
JIM: He'll be back in
about three to four weeks.
CHRIS: That camping trip
he talked about, weirdly,
weirdly wedged into his
conversation last week.
MODERATOR: Yeah, and
I guess to that end,
you know a lot has
been already said
in the press about the last day
of filming with Donald Glover
before he went off on
the childish tycoon,
but what I really
want to know what
were the days leading
up to the last day?
ALISON: Well, I mean I've said
this before because I actually
think it's funny that we shot
the episodes out of order.
So like the days leading
up to his actual departure
were totally uneventful for him.
We were shooting--
CHRIS: We were shooting
"Ass Crack Bandits," which
was technically 505,
our fifth episode.
ALISON: So it was
like we did all--
I felt like everyone was very
emotional when we were shooting
the scene with the
childish tycoon,
and he's going to
leave, and everyone's
like we're hugging him
goodbye, and it felt very real.
And then the next
week we're like hey.
CHRIS: It's the one with
the quarters in your butt.
DANNY: That's very normal.
CHRIS: I was there for
his very last shot,
and it was like 5:00 in
the morning on Saturday.
And it was literally a shot
of Donald's butt bending over
[INAUDIBLE].
Like perfect.
DANNY: Symbolism.
ALISON: He went out
the way he came in.
JIM: Wait he came in?
ALISON: Oh, you
don't know the story
about how Donald got the job?
DANNY: Tell us.
Guys.
JIM: So bookends, literally.
MODERATOR: All right,
that's good stuff.
ALISON: Yep.
MODERATOR: Also looking at
season five, do any of you
have any particular
favorite story
lines that have
been done so far?
DANNY: I'm excited about the
episode that we have coming up.
ALISON: Yes.
DANNY: We have an
episode where-- What can
I say about that one?
ALISON: Can he say what
we do in the episode?
CHRIS: Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's
already out there, so yeah.
JIM: Just keep whispering and--
DANNY: Because they
don't know what
we're talking
about that episode.
JIM: Is it OK if we
talk about that one.
CHRIS: And don't spoil
who's in the thing.
DANNY: Oh, OK.
OK.
Well, we have an
episode coming up.
CHRIS: It's great.
It's a great roommate episode.
DANNY: It's a roommate episode.
ALISON: Yeah, it's
this roommate episode.
DANNY: Based on Troy leaving.
So we have to find
a new roommate.
Can I say that?
CHRIS: Yes.
Yeah sure.
ALISON: We have to
find a new roommate,
and we're sort of vying for
our options of the roommate.
But to settle the score--
To settle the score?
No.
DANNY: To settle, well
to find a roommate--
ALISON: We play this
like VCR, this like--
DANNY: '80's
interactive VCR game.
ALISON: VCR, yeah.
DANNY: So, it's really--
CHRIS: They get
a little into it.
And it's really confusing
and doesn't make any sense.
ALISON: And it was so
confusing to shoot.
DANNY: Because we were
trying to establish rules.
ALISON: And they
shot separately.
So we're all just looking at
like green X's on the screen,
and we're like coordinating,
jumping up, spinning around,
like shooting things.
DANNY: Pulling
tokens, rolling dice.
ALISON: So, go token four!
CHRIS: And the two people--
DANNY: Tornado.
Tornado!
ALISON: Tornado!
I'm not going to do it.
DANNY: Tornado!
ALISON: Tornado!
DANNY: We got it.
We still got it.
We still got it Chris.
CHRIS: Alison won and Jim
has to be your roommate now.
ALISON: Yay!
CHRIS: It's a great episode.
JIM: No, literally in real life.
ALISON: Oh.
JIM: It was a pun.
ALISON: That was a twist.
JIM: Like a meta real
life and art thing.
Yeah, we're living together.
It's great.
CHRIS: We have another episode
coming up where these three--
DANNY: Oh yeah.
CHRIS: These three
make a discovery
and go on a little adventure,
or head up this adventure
together.
And I thought that
the way that the three
of you, because each of
you, each of your characters
has a little bit of
insanity and take things
a little too seriously.
DANNY: Thank you Chris.
CHRIS: But that's
going to be the finale.
We have a two part finale,
and they sort of head
the sort of Scooby
Doo mystery that they
pull the rest of the group into.
DANNY: That episode
was really fun for us
because it was one of the few
times where all three of us
were paired together for
the whole like storyline.
And it was fun watching
how crazy our energy was
in the scenes with
everyone else.
ALISON: Oh my god, and then
the other people would come in.
We'd be like in a little
bottle like shooting stuff
just the three of
us, and then we'd
bring in the rest of
the cast, and they'd all
be like you guys
gotta calm down.
DANNY: What has been
going on this week?
And they're like no it's OK.
Rob, [INAUDIBLE] and
Chris said it's cool.
They said it's cool
to be this energetic.
ALISON: We would jump and
down and yell our macho words
to each other really loud
and then restart the scene,
and everyone was like
what are you doing?
We've never done this here.
CHRIS: It's great.
We were just editing
that episode together,
and you guys come bursting
in, and are very excited
and feeding off each
other, and it's insane.
It's great.
ALISON: While also while
we were shooting it
we didn't really know
what we were shooting.
So that added to
the manic energy.
The episodes were sort of being
written as we went and halfway
through we decided that one
was coming before the-- I
shouldn't.
Chris'll say don't say that.
CHRIS: No, no, no.
Oh, god.
It's insane.
We usually don't know
what's happening.
ALISON: That was a
particularly interesting one
where you and Dan
were sort of on set
being like here's
what's happening.
We're like OK.
CHRIS: We shot the second
part of the two part finale
before we shot the first part.
ALISON: But we didn't know
it was the second part.
CHRIS: And we didn't
even know what
was happening in the first part.
DANNY: So we knew
where we were going.
We just didn't know why
we were going there.
CHRIS: I think the
theory was, look,
we know we're going to send
them on this adventure,
and we're not sure
how we set that up,
and we'll just figure
that out because we
have to write the
second part of it.
You guys do code like
that all the time right?
DANNY: Yeah.
This is Google.
It's the same thing.
CHRIS: Yeah, we may have
written ourselves into a corner,
but I think it's going
to turn out pretty great.
DANNY: That's part of I think
the fun of our show too.
CHRIS: What can we tell them
that maybe had some details?
Tell them a little about
this week's episode?
MODERATOR: Sure,
they saw a preview.
DANNY: Meow-Meow Beans.
CHRIS: Oh did you guys just
watch the Meow Meow Beans?
Things get a little weird.
ALISON: Someone will be
wearing a blousey shirt later.
CHRIS: Things descend
into "Logan's Run" because
of this social media
app where people
are rated either a five, a
four, a three, a two, or a one.
ALISON: Everyone gets
to rate each other.
DANNY: There's a whole
hierarchy that's developed.
I love episodes like this
where we start a cold open
and then you cut to, immediately
after the commercials,
the whole campus, everyone,
is immediately-- There's
a new language, a new
culture, a new fashion.
I mean within three
minutes everything changes.
JIM: This school
changes on a dime.
New costume for me.
Worlds are created.
CHRIS: Classes, what classes?
JIM: Classes.
No.
CHRIS: So this one it was weird.
This was an experimental
one where we didn't come out
like in "Modern Warfare
Paintball" where we came out
of the cold open.
We thought oh, no, no, no,
we'll eventually get there,
and that was a much harsher,
and it was like, oh wait, no.
It's so much better to
have like the cold open
then you go into lunacy.
I think it works now.
We figured it out,
but for a little while
they were like, oh
man, did we break TV?
It's definitely one of
my favorite episodes.
DANNY: We were shooting
in the study room,
and they just kept
bringing in random props.
I don't know if you remember.
CHRIS: The white room?
DANNY: Yeah, in the white room.
And just kept adding
things and being
like-- we were discovering
the environment
while we were shooting it.
ALISON: It's a common
theme of how we shoot.
DANNY: People too.
And this episode has some of my
favorite guest star appearances
ever in our show.
CHRIS: Oh, we have--
DANNY: I won't tell them, but--
ALISON: "Tim and
Eric Awesome Show."
CHRIS: Tim and Eric are in it.
Mitch Hurwitz, the creator
of "Arrested Development"
is in it, and hilarious.
ALISON: Mitch Hurwitz is
so funny in this episode
and was such a funny
guy all the time.
I feel like it was our
favorite week of shooting just
having Mitch around, and
everyone's like do things.
Talk in front of us.
And everyone was on good
behavior cause we're like
and whenever you're
making something else--
DANNY: Yeah, we're available.
We're probably available.
ALISON: We act.
CHRIS: Look at this episode.
There's no way we're
getting a sixth season.
I mean people are wearing
bed sheets and it's nonsense.
And the funny thing
with Mitch though
it was someone who had
run a show before--
ALISON: Was the most disruptive.
CHRIS: It was like
having a live animal on.
He was like running around,
not saying his lines,
and being ridiculous.
Luckily he had some of
the funniest ad libs.
ALISON: Mitch, just say
it how it's written.
And he'd be like yeah,
yeah, and then he'd
just go do a monologue
of his own device.
CHRIS: Yeah, and then
Ken Jeong would just
be laughing hysterically
and break it every take.
DANNY: Ken cannot stop laughing.
That's right.
CHRIS: That's why we're
a million dollars over.
ALISON: But Ken is
having a great time.
DANNY: We do have a good time.
MODERATOR: And of
course Nathan Fillion
made a pretty amazing guest.
ALISON: Yes.
I was actually-- I was
going to say-- Oh, that
was-- Never mind.
That was a fun episode to shoot.
Carry on.
MODERATOR: All right.
So I'd like to shift a little
bit to the characterization
and how things have
changed in this season.
So I'll start with you Danny.
So in last week's episode,
the "Bondage and Beta Male
Sexuality" Abed really had
some very pivotal scenes,
and so he got a lot stronger.
I wanted to say how did
you approach these scenes?
Is Abed more comfortable
being his true self
with this group of people, or
is this just how he really is?
CHRIS: And what
happened to your nose?
DANNY: A lot of things.
I broke my nose this
season, and that
was the episode, this last
week, where I broke my nose.
So I don't know
if you could tell.
ALISON: Only the episode
where you had the most to do.
CHRIS: And the most
dramatic close-ups.
DANNY: I break my nose.
They're like hey,
we need you back on
set as I'm coming
from the doctor.
And they're like we want to
try this mask on your nose.
And I'm like I
just broke my nose.
They're like yeah, we want
to just see how this--
ALISON: How this metal mask.
DANNY: So we had to figure
out that kick-puncher mask,
but I love this
episode because it
was sort of like how are we
going to address not having
that Troy Abed dynamic.
And I think it was
kind of fun to just
be paired up with someone.
And Jonathon Banks is
very different, has
a different sort of style.
And it was fun.
It felt kind of different.
It was just a new thing that we,
we talked about this this year,
in terms of acting it
was like it was cool
this year because
we had a chance
to do very different stuff
that we haven't really done.
We had two person scenes.
We had some more
slower paced scenes,
which is really interesting.
JIM: I think from the very
beginning there was a decision,
and it felt like you guys.
One it was the re-pilot
of it, but this evolution
of all these guys,
because you're
dealing with the
loss of a friend,
and coming through
Jonathan Banks'
character, and this
new evolution of Abed.
And I think it was across the
board the mandate it felt like.
It was not just about
pairing other people up.
It just felt like it was about
realizing that life moves on
and these same
people keep evolving.
And it's a great thing that
we've had with "Community"
because we don't know what's
coming down the pipeline.
We're able to like push
that story and just say,
well, this is what
happened last year,
and these are the ramifications.
I thought that was a nice thing.
But that particular
episode, when you watch it,
is such a nice
evolution of Abed.
DANNY: And I think
this year, in terms
of like-- I've said I think
Abed's changed and grown
the most this year than of all
the seasons, and some of it
is because we had to deal
with certain changes.
But I think that was
kind of cool, because we
took some of those things that
were happening like, you know,
Pierce being gone
and Troy leaving,
and we just applied it, and
just see what else happens.
So I actually really liked it.
I thought it was really fun to
kind of have these two person
scenes where these
two characters come
from very different places.
Yeah.
It was exciting.
CHRIS: You're
going to be excited
when you get stubbed
for an Emmy again.
DANNY: Oh, yay!
ALISON: I'll be excited for you.
DANNY: That's OK.
If we come back for a sixth
season that's [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS: That's one of my
favorite episodes ever.
I mean Danny, all
of you guys kill it.
That was just such a great-- you
front and center just bringing
that character to life.
And it was one of
those things that
were like you said
we're always trying--
the most interesting
stuff on the show
always comes from dealing with
stuff that's actually happening
in the reality of the
show, and writing up to it,
and dealing with Troy's
loss, and not having
to be this thing
that's haunting you,
but something we
just had to address.
And plus we had
this new character
that we loved that we
will really just go, oh,
this guy is not going to be
buying any of Abed's bullshit.
So it was really fun.
And "Community" is a
place for broken people,
and Hickey fits
right into that mold,
and that sort of like that
"Taxi" sensibility of people
who are still trying to figure
out life and their own lives,
and no matter how old they
are or how young they are.
I thought the two of you
coming together on that story
was really great.
MODERATOR: And we're
also seeing a much more
grown up Annie this season.
ALISON: Yeah.
MODERATOR: So anything that we
should be on the lookout for?
ALISON: A lot of your pants.
More pants.
MODERATOR: More jeans?
ALISON: A lot of
people on Twitter
have been commenting
on these pants.
They're not going
anywhere people.
DANNY: Are they mad
about the pants?
ALISON: Some people are
mad about the pants.
CHRIS: I can't
believe a "Community"
fan would have a
really intense--
ALISON: A strong reaction
CHRIS: Reaction to something.
JIM: A visceral
reaction to your pants.
ALISON: No.
It's great.
And that's something
that I had talked to Dan
a little bit about
before we started.
And we talk about re-pilot and
the characters moving forward,
but also I think in
moving forward there
was a lot of grounding them
in sort of the stuff that
made them who they were
in our first season.
So I felt like over
the years there
was this departure from
the original like go-getter
Annie that was like
very determined,
and a hard worker, and
ambitious, and all that stuff.
And that had gotten muddled.
And this year we've
really returned to it,
and her being a sort of
moral center for the group,
but is crazy in that way.
That's her craziness.
Craziness.
It's coming out of me.
DANNY: [SHRIEKING]
ALISON: But it's really fun.
I way prefer.
I just as much prefer
that side of her
because I think it gets
the other characters going.
It's like a much
more interesting way
to interact with
characters rather than
just like having a crush on
them or something like that.
It's back to like season one
when she and Jeff were working
for the newspaper, and she's
like I've got a major scoop.
I kind of like Annie in a
like detective position,
or that we're having
forensics, criminology.
I loved the "Ass
Crack Bandit" episode.
That was so fun to shoot.
I just like that side of her.
MODERATOR: And Jim, I guess we
have much more of the faculty
dynamic this season as well.
So what's that been like?
How have things been different
for the life of the dean?
JIM: Yeah, cause
we've had John Oliver,
and then Professor
Hickey added, and then
obviously Jeff's evolution.
It's been fun.
I mean instantly it was fun just
because once again the dean is
not allowed to be
in a certain area.
So that established
very quickly that I
wasn't allowed in
the teacher's lounge.
I probably helped them
get half of that stuff.
So I just liked that it was nice
because the dean just really
still loves a school that seems
to fight against him every step
of the way, you know because
his ideas are so horrible,
which makes sense.
And again I think
that speaks more
to what's the evolution of Jeff,
which was so nice, to put him
in this position where
he's between his friends
and this new sort of
career that he's probably
fighting tooth and
nail to be a part of.
And obviously Hickey
is such a great sort
of roommate, if
you will, for that.
So again, it just sort of
fit the whole big picture.
MODERATOR: Awesome.
Awesome.
And when Dan originally
pitched this show
he said it was about an asshole
who learned to love strangers.
So is that still true?
How do you approach like
the overall character arcs?
CHRIS: I think Dan
loves some people now.
It's funny.
I think obviously
Jeff is a stand
in for Dan in a lot of ways.
I think every one of the
characters he created
is a different facet of Dan.
But, yeah, Jeff I think
it came out of Dan, Dan
going to actually
Glendale Community College
and getting pulled
into a study group.
And in he's admittedly I think
sort of an anti-social person.
And I think watching
that evolution
it's the same thing with Dan.
Dan, his first
instinct is not to sit
in a room full of other
writers and write.
He wants to hole up
and do his thing.
And I think an interesting
meta element to all
of this is that,
as Dan has said,
is that he was forced because
of how the system is set up
is he has to hire
writers, and he
has to sit in a
room with people,
and he has to hear
different ideas.
And I came on
first season, and I
was one of those people
I'm sure he hated because I
opened my mouth, and I you know.
But I think he grew to sort
of love the strangers that he
was writing with, and I
think that is definitely
reflected in Jeff's
journey on the show.
MODERATOR: And when
writing these characters
do you have an idea of
where you want everyone
to end up, like this happily
ever after world, or?
CHRIS: We really try not to.
I think that's when we write
ourselves into trouble.
When you already know
what the end point is I
think we write ourselves
into troublesome areas.
And I would say third
season Dan had to go to NBC,
and he had to pitch
the whole season out
to-- This is what we're doing.
This is everyone's arc.
This is their four quadrant
arc for the season down to
from Jeff to Chang.
And I think great
stuff came out of that,
but I think those kind of
things then they bind you.
And then you're feeling,
oh, well you know,
this is where Chang
is head of security,
but this is before he
takes over the school.
And you just find that
you don't have fun just
to be in the sandbox and
create with the characters.
And I loved third season, and I
think we were able to do that.
We were able to do something
like multiple timelines
and have the episode
where the two of you guys
went in the Dreamatorium.
But I think it's so much
fun to discover a journey
rather than set an endpoint
and say this is where it is.
MODERATOR: And so how are
things in the writers room?
Are you still writing to
the wee hours of the morning
the night before a shoot?
CHRIS: We wrapped in December
and we're still writing.
I am not kidding.
We have an animated episode
that Dan and I have definitely,
definitely had a
recent all-nighter on.
Like are you kidding me?
It's now January and we're
pulling an all-nighter.
It's going to be great.
ALISON: It'll be great.
We record it next week.
CHRIS: What's that?
ALISON: I said we
record it next week.
CHRIS: Oh yeah, you guys
are going to record it.
And it airs the following week.
We're doing an
animated episode that
is in the style of the 1980's
animated series "GI Joe."
AUDIENCE: Oh yes!
CHRIS: And it's
going to be great.
It's really fantastic.
MODERATOR: Cool.
Cool.
And I guess along
that line too one
of things I think "Community"
does really strongly
is lampoon, pay homage to a
variety of TV genres, TV shows.
You know you did the
Nicolas Cage episode.
So you sort of have that check
box done from years and years.
So anything else on the
docket that you'd like to do?
Or any unexplored territory?
CHRIS: Dan I always, it's funny,
we were meeting with writers
last year and we're
like, look, we're
not going to be concept first.
You know we're not
going to do-- That's
when we get into trouble.
We're not going to
go, oh, we're doing
you know a "Logan's
Run" episode.
Or we're not going to
say we're doing another D
and D because then the
tail's wagging the dog.
Cut to bashing our head
against the wall going
why did we say we're
doing another Dungeons
and Dragons episode?
How are we going to
crack this story?
If a story then takes
on an element that
has a concept to
it, that has, you
know, a feeling of a genre
then we'll run towards that.
But we really do try
not to just say, oh,
now we're doing our buddy cop
space movie cause then we're
bashing our heads going, wait,
how is Abed on the moon now?
Why?
Why is that the moon.
It makes no sense.
So that said we have some
concepts coming, and the "GI
Joe" one.
This week's definitely takes
a very sci-fi-ish kind of feel
to it.
ALISON: '70s sci-fi.
CHRIS: Sort of '70s sci-fi,
"Logan's Run" inspired.
Rob Schrab directed it.
Rob is brilliant.
He's Dan's old partner.
They created "Heat Vision
and Jack" together.
And he's a brilliant director.
Really has a great visual style.
And we let him run.
There's stuff that you
will see in this episode
that we kept on going if anyone
from the studio or the network
came by right now-- You dressed
in white robes in a white room
with orbs on your hand doing
a crazy Buck Rogers dance.
They would shut us down.
But luckily they
don't ever come--
ALISON: They don't come by.
DANNY: No one knows we're
still doing this show.
We're winning.
CHRIS: Yeah.
DANNY: My favorite
visual of I think
the year is in this
episode, the first time you
see Hickey in the--
CHRIS: Yes.
Yep.
DANNY: I just need to
say that, because it
is-- I remember when
I showed up on set,
and I didn't really know what
was going on in the episode,
and I already saw him in the
wardrobe, and I was shocked.
And this is after five
seasons of doing this show.
I was shocked by
what I was seeing.
That was a good feeling.
CHRIS: Definitely Rob took
the visuals of this episode
and ran to crazy town with them.
It's really one of
my favorite episodes.
And Ludwig, our composer, did
a really cool synth treatment
of the music for it.
And I'm probably giving
way too much away,
but watch it this Thursday.
ALISON: You'll still watch it.
MODERATOR: We have it on
the DVR, on the Google Play.
JIM: Heard enough.
Sick [INAUDIBLE].
I'm out.
MODERATOR: And I think
another fun trope that's
been going around is the idea
that all the NBC shows are
set in this sort of
similar universe.
So you have "Community" and
"Chuck" doing a slight overlap,
and then it sort of
expands to things
like "Cougar Town" for
example, and "Parks and Rec."
Like what crossovers is
the world ready for now?
Like Annie is the
next Leslie Knope.
You know Ron Swanson after
some chicken fingers.
CHRIS: They're running out
of shows unfortunately.
to do crossovers with.
Or there's what?
There's "Parks and Rec" and us.
So we're the last man standing.
What? "Game Night?"
Yeah, do a "Community"
"Game Night."
JIM: "Community"
"Game Night," yeah.
MODERATOR: Well Greendale
and Colorado and Indiana--
CHRIS: Chicago PD?
ALISON: Yeah.
DANNY: Chicago Fire?
ALISON: I like the "Parks
and Rec" crossover idea.
So many good people.
So many possibles,
possibilities for connections,
to meet different people.
MODERATOR: I'm sure there's
criminology in Pawnee that
needs answered as well.
ALISON: And where
there is criminology--
JIM: Oh lord those pants--
ALISON: I'll be there.
JIM: Those pants.
ALISON: You will not
find those jeans.
DANNY: [INAUDIBLE]!
MODERATOR: Interesting.
So we'll have time for a
few audience questions.
So if you want to queue
up we can go to those.
I have some as well about
"Community," the future.
So you know coming up on
100 episodes, that's really
a good milestone, great
milestone for a lot of TV
shows.
What does that mean to you?
ALISON: Well, we're
not quite there yet.
CHRIS: Yeah, we got--
DANNY: We got 97?
CHRIS: 97.
Or 96 if we don't finish
this animated one.
JIM: We're very close.
CHRIS: Yeah, 97.
I feel like, 100, it's
arbitrary I guess.
I'm excited about
our own arbitrary one
that the fans created, the
six seasons and a movie.
If we could actually
pull that off I
think that would be the
way to end this mother,
land it, pat each other on
the back, see each other,
I don't know, on Donald's
effects show doing cameos.
ALISON: Crossover!
DANNY: Or catering.
MODERATOR: And speaking of
the homages of other shows
you have.
You have you know
the "Scrubs" theme,
"Who's the Boss," et cetera.
Picture some unknown
show in the future,
like show to be determined.
What do they need
to do to capture
the essence of a
"Community" allusion.
CHRIS: Kinda 1.0.
I don't know.
What do you guys think?
DANNY: I don't know.
I mean I think smashing people
who seemingly don't seem
like they should be friends
are put together in one place.
That's one thing we did.
ALISON: That is a thing we did.
It would be tough to do
a "Community" homage.
I don't how people would--
because our show to me
is so many different things.
JIM: I don't think we
have specific voice, which
is so wonderful about this show.
CHRIS: It's like
staring into the sun.
Like putting a
mirror into a mirror.
MODERATOR: Infinity.
Cool.
I can see I have some
audience questions.
Go ahead sir.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm wondering when
you guys have the movie, which
you're obviously
going to have, what
do you wish you could
do in the movie?
Like if it were up
to you guys what's
something you would
love to do in the movie
like you can't do
in a TV show format?
ALISON: Time travel.
DANNY: Yeah.
ALISON: Cause that
happens in movies, not TV.
DANNY: Yeah, TV
doesn't do any of that.
I can't think of one
time travel TV show.
ALISON: But we could
make it work in a movie.
DANNY: Not a long
one, not a short one.
ALISON: Movies.
DANNY: Time travel, you
can do that in movies.
CHRIS: I would just be
so interested to see
who we're going to cast
as your characters.
I mean there are really some
great, great, oh my god,
Chris Evans as Abed?
DANNY: Yes.
He would be such a good--
He would be a better Abed.
CHRIS: Oh my god, yeah.
JIM: A-list playing our
parts would be fantastic.
It would be nice to do
a movie where there's
a movie in the movie with
A-list actors playing us.
And we're just
watching ourselves.
CHRIS: Well, at the very
least the trailer, just
to trick people
into the theater.
DANNY: I need to see this movie.
JIM: The exciting
thing about a movie
would be getting
to shoot outside.
CHRIS: Yes.
ALISON: Yes.
JIM: The idea of
what it would look
like if sun naturally
hit our face.
DANNY: People always ask us
like what do you guys shoot at?
And we're like we shoot inside
of one stage, everything,
always.
JIM: Well that wasn't inside.
We used to go outside, and
then, you know, things happen.
CHRIS: The accountants sit there
with a calculator going, nope,
sun is too much.
Nope.
Stay inside.
We've got makeup for that.
We got makeup to look
like you've been outside.
No, honestly it's
one of the things
I've been saying to Dan,
if there's a sixth season,
we got to figure out a
way to get back outside.
I mean because it's
just expensive.
There was a little
episode called "Hot Lava"
that broke the bank very early
on, and had people yelling,
doing this a lot for the rest
of like the next three months,
no, no, no.
And let's not do concept
episodes anywhere.
Let's just at least be able to
go outside to the Lucy Park.
And it's funny, I
catch occasionally,
like I'm flipping
channels, and I
see like episodes where
I'm like, oh yeah,
we used to go outside.
ALISON: We used to
walk through the quad.
CHRIS: Yeah.
DANNY: Remember our first scene.
We were walking outside.
ALISON: Walking outside.
DANNY: Aw, it felt so good.
ALISON: Yeah.
CHRIS: So yeah, aren't you
excited to see outdoors.
Aren't you excited to go sit
in a dark theater and watch
the sun?
DANNY: We don't need much.
AUDIENCE: Ass Crack
Bandit you guys
were outside [INAUDIBLE]
Hall but it was raining.
JIM: Yeah.
You can step just outside.
ALISON: Just step outside, yeah.
MODERATOR: And bring a new
light of day to "Community."
Thank you guys so much.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Jim, what's
your favorite costume
that the dean has worn.
JIM: In all the years?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, across the--
JIM: Across the universe?
I don't know.
I mean I always feel like I can
never not reference the five
entrances from our
first clip episode
because it was just such a joy
to shoot because they just sort
of set the camera up, and I
would run off, get made up
into the new one, come in while
Gillian and Joel would just
change little
outfit we'd put on.
A remote control car.
We don't know what
that storyline was.
CHRIS: Well that was
the one with a callback
to the quadrocopter, when you
guys got into the quadrocopter.
JIM: So I mean that
whole sort of run
of costumes was great,
from Tina Turner to--
ALISON: You made
a hot Tina Turner.
JIM: Well, thank you.
Thank you.
Yes.
I learned how to walk
in high heels that year.
That's for sure.
And now I can't stop.
MODERATOR: New York
Fashion Week on the docket.
CHRIS: I will say
in no this week,
but the following week
the dean is in a costume
and also does one of the
funniest things I've ever seen.
It's episode 509.
JIM: Yeah, that was fun.
CHRIS: I don't want to spoil it.
I'll just peanut.
I'll just say the word peanut.
JIM: Yes.
It was a blast, but
a stressful blast.
Yeah, anyway you'll see.
CHRIS: It's in the cold open.
You don't even have to
watch it after that.
You just watch the
first two minutes
and then go over to "BAZINGA"
ALISON: I don't
even remember what
happens in the rest
of that episode.
CHRIS: That's the
roommate episode.
ALISON: Ohh
DANNY: You already forgot us?
JIM: You get two great things.
You get the long story you
told about the roommate thing,
and you get this one
in the cold open.
MODERATOR: So it
ties it all together.
JIM: Yeah.
MODERATOR: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Well, since no one's behind
me I can quick follow up.
Danny, in your words
Nicolas Cage good or bad?
ALISON: Ooo, in your words.
DANNY: Good.
ALISON: Good job.
DANNY: Thank you so much.
CHRIS: Nailed it.
DANNY: We fight about it,
but yeah, I think it's good.
I think we do need
that person and help
us question whether
it is good or bad.
I think good.
CHRIS: Now we're
just going to run
a 20 minute take of
you doing Nicolas.
We have so many
outtakes from that.
We were just watching him
on the monitor and howling,
and then they make
him do it again.
DANNY: Yeah, talk
about having to get rid
of any self consciousness.
When me and Dan Harmon
are behind like the set
practicing Nicolas
Cage impressions
and just doing sexy cat voices.
Dan's is really good, yeah.
Yeah, sexy cat.
MODERATOR: So is
that a DVD special
feature we should be
on the lookout for?
CHRIS: Should be.
Absolutely.
I hope so.
Oh, speaking of DVD, I was
thinking remember the first DVD
at the end of the year Dan did
employee performance reviews.
DANNY: Yes!
I
JIM: Yes.
CHRIS: Should you guys do
peer performance reviews?
How did you guys do this season?
JIM: Oh.
Oh, nice.
CHRIS: Alison and Danny, do Jim.
JIM: Oh, thank you.
ALISON: Jim.
JIM: That speaks volumes.
DANNY: Good or bad Jim?
JIM: Wait, aren't you
supposed to evaluate me?
DANNY: Are we?
JIM: This feels
just like it, yes.
You're evaluating me.
You want me to say how I felt?
DANNY: Why don't we
start there and just see
where that leads us.
JIM: I felt like I did my best,
DANNY: You can cry.
You can cry.
JIM: And I did what I
thought I should do.
ALISON: That was great.
DANNY: Next!
ALISON: Next!
ALISON: Do you have
a question sir?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
I think "Community"s done a
great job of being absolutely
not normal at all in every way.
ALISON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
if you guys have ever
considered any cliche ideas
like actual couples developing
or long term romances
like you seem
to see in all the other
sitcoms these days?
DANNY: Three cameras.
CHRIS: The thing
that's keeping us
from being a popular
sitcom you want to see?
I don't know.
How do you guys feel?
ALISON: Well it
happened last season.
You know, Britta and Troy
dated for the entire season.
Well, and then they broke up.
We sort of saw their entire
relationship over the season,
and I thought it
was super weird.
I don't know.
I thought it was strange.
I think the problem is that
we've set up this group as such
a thing, and it's the
group is the thing.
It's a family.
And even though we've made all
those jokes in the first season
about how everyone could be
sexually attracted to everyone,
and I still think that's true,
it just functions as a family,
and everyone loves each other.
And it's this unit.
And it just seems
a little forced,
or something feels
unnatural I feel
like when you try to go
too far in that direction.
I mean I love the
Jeff and Annie stuff.
I love working with Joel and I
love exploring that chemistry,
but even that by now feels like
it would be so strange to just
be like Jeff and
Annie are dating now,
and they're like walking
down the halls holding hands.
It just doesn't
quite fit our show.
CHRIS: It's tough,
because I know
there's lots of people out
there, the shippers, who
want Annie and Jeff or Annie
and-- I mean Annie and Britta.
ALISON: Annie and Britta.
There are.
There are those people.
CHRIS: I stumbled on to
that web page accidentally.
ALISON: Stumbled on to it.
CHRIS: You know,
Jeff and Britta.
They just want somebody,
something to be shipping.
It is tough, because when you
created a family like this
you don't really--
it's a bottle that's
tough to once you
uncork it to cork.
And it's one of those
things we've talked about,
and I know a lot of
other sitcoms do it.
And I will say the romance
stuff, on other sitcoms,
and it's just my taste, usually
I'm not that interested in it.
I'm not interested.
I'm interested in how these
people are relating as friends,
how they've betrayed
each other as friends,
whether the paternal
elements that Jeff has,
or whether he's acting
like a child in relation
to some of the other characters.
It was always more
interesting to me,
but, you know,
I'm super asexual.
I don't know.
ALISON: Well, I was
gonna say our characters
are almost kind of asexual.
None of our characters
are really like sexy.
I mean I guess Jeff is.
JIM: Well.
ALISON: OK.
I'm sorry.
I apologize.
DANNY: Sorry Jim.
JIM: I'm super sexy.
I just feel like I'm very sexy.
ALISON: Dean is very sexy.
And Jeff is sexy.
CHRIS: He's a director now.
You can't say those
things to him.
ALISON: Well in person.
I'm talking about
our characters Jim.
JIM: No, no, no.
I get it.
We'll talk later.
ALISON: But I do feel like
everyone's sort of interested
in other things, and
that just doesn't
seem to be like a high
priority for these people.
I mean that said I do
find it interesting
when we see other
people brought in
to be love interests
outside the group.
That I think is interesting.
CHRIS: And I think
we'll see how,
if this show even continues how
romance will rear it's head.
And it seems to me
that that's the way
to do it if you're
going to do it.
And you know the circling the
wagons these people who are now
like brothers and sisters
like when a stranger enters
the midst and being
threatened by it.
Obviously there's
still feelings there,
and I think these characters are
still confused about themselves
and their lives that they
don't-- I think sometimes there
is some Jeff stuff coming up
in terms of his feelings about
people in the group, and I
think still he has a hard time
differentiating between whether
something is erotic love
or love of these people that
he cares so deeply about.
MODERATOR: And along those
lines coat check girl?
Will we see any
more on that end?
CHRIS: Oh yeah,
they start dating.
I forgot.
ALISON: But see.
It's someone outside the group.
Outside the group.
CHRIS: Yeah, Brie
Larson, who's great,
we have coming up on 509.
MODERATOR: Cool.
So I had a few small
questions as well.
One thing that I really
enjoy about "Community"
is just the amount of callbacks.
You know Britta got the
iPad Nano this season.
So check mark on that.
How do you keep
track of all that?
Is there a master list of things
that you need to go back from?
CHRIS: Yes.
It's called fans on
Twitter constantly
bothering Harmon
about when's Britta
going to get her iPad Nano?
We go oh yeah.
And so it worked out perfectly.
No, but believe me.
That's the system.
People don't stop bothering
Dan, and thank god.
Because that was
a great callback.
MODERATOR: Another
question right here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'll ask a question for Jim.
For "Freaky Friday" you
got to suddenly write
for these characters
who you were
like alongside for
most of the show.
Has like suddenly having
more power over the universe
giving you this like feeling
of-- Has the power corrupted
basically is the question?
JIM: Are you asking
if personally--?
ALISON: I mean he
thinks he's very sexy.
JIM: Yeah well.
ALISON: I mean he is.
JIM: Personally do I have more
power now that that happened?
I feel like these two
put me on a pedestal.
Is that fair?
DANNY: Oh I worship
you immediately.
JIM: Thank you.
Thank you.
No, I was so lucky to
have had that experience
because at least I love this
show sort of unconditionally.
And I feel like the
beauty of getting
to write "Community" is that
the voices are so clear,
and what was created
was so clear.
So no, because I always--
to answer your question, no.
I don't think it
changed anything to me
other than that I
got an opportunity
to do something
that was wonderful.
MODERATOR: Well
it's not every day
we have an Academy Award
winning person on the show.
JIM: Who speaks so eloquently.
MODERATOR: So another
few small questions.
What do you think
happened to the cool study
group over the
past five seasons?
The one with Jack--
CHRIS: One was in a movie
about Google I thought.
MODERATOR: Oh, that's
"Internship", college.
I should've known that answer
when I wrote the question.
All right.
And you also had a big reveal
about Starburns this year.
What do you think he's been up
to since the days of the Ass
Crack Bandit?
DANNY: Probably
doing a lot of math.
CHRIS: He does do math.
He does like it.
Building well.
Definitely researching cat cars.
And hoarding, lurking.
He's like that
movie "Bad Ronald."
I think he's just sort of
living in the walls of Greendale
and stealing people's
food, and watching them.
But anything he can do probably
to smoke and try to get high
I'm guessing?
JIM: Yeah.
I mean, you know
the repercussions
of doing something horrible
at our school has very little.
There are very little.
As far as I'm concerned he's
just wondering, you know.
He took a bullet and that's it.
I think the best
thing about Greendale
is it just sort of
erases what happened.
Let's just move on.
CHRIS: Well, yeah, no.
We've got something else.
We got like there's a
fire in the cafeteria.
No there's always some new
nonsense to distract everyone.
So the dean's always got
some new harebrained scheme.
JIM: Right.
MODERATOR: And the
dean is the rug
under which
everything gets swept.
JIM: Oh, there's a
paper trail leading
to every single character
and what they did wrong.
So I feel like it's OK.
Everyone's in the same boat.
Look, we fucked up.
We get it.
MODERATOR: So you all
display some really,
really cool hidden
talents, and I actually
saw Alison in concert a few
weeks ago at SF Sketchfest,
which was pretty amazing.
ALISON: Thank you!
MODERATOR: Yeah.
So my pleasure.
I'm glad that the
tickets worked out.
And anything else that we'll
be seeing hidden talent wise,
or that you'd like to display?
ALISON: Danny.
DANNY: March 12, I have a ESPN
30 for 30 short coming out
called "Untucked " on Grantland.
Please watch it.
It's about basketball jerseys
and why I should never
be playing basketball.
ALISON: Yes.
He directed it and everything.
DANNY: I directed it.
But it was fun.
ALISON: Where is it coming out?
Say it again.
DANNY: It's an ESPN
30 for 30 short
called "Untucked" on Grantland.
ALISON: What's Grantland?
DANNY: It's a website.
It's an ESPN ish kind of website
about sports topics of the day
and that kind of thing.
So every month they
have a short now.
And it's a little peak into
Marquette basketball history,
their jerseys.
It's fun.
It's about 1977's championship
team and a journey that
was designed by [INAUDIBLE]
Ellis, a player on the team.
So check it out.
MODERATOR: Anything
on your deck Jim?
JIM: No, no, no.
No I'm just kidding.
MODERATOR: [INAUDIBLE].
Watching people go
down the water slides.
JIM: Yeah that's pretty much it.
No, yeah, just back to writing.
You know, trying to.
I know that was way boring.
MODERATOR: Writing's important.
CHRIS: You just
directed a Fox pilot.
Come on.
JIM: Yes, we did do that.
CHRIS: You just got to go hang
out in Burbank and watch people
testing it.
JIM: We tested it, yes.
No, Nat and I did
direct a pilot for Fox.
So we'll see.
MODERATOR: Cool.
And I also from Vickie,
to Fat Neal, to Garrett,
I really like the
back stories that
are so prevalent in the
supporting characters.
And were there
any cool anecdotes
with working with them
that you'd like to share?
CHRIS: You guys work with
them probably more closely.
ALISON: I know.
Well, I would like to
say before anecdotes
that I love-- Our supporting
characters are great,
like the fabric that makes
up Greendale the college.
And over the years we've just
held on to so many of them.
And they're all
wonderful people,
except for Paradox
was my favorite
and he's never come back.
DANNY: There was like 2
years where we'd always say I
[INAUDIBLE].
ALISON: [INAUDIBLE]
DANNY: And that
was his one line.
ALISON: It was his one line.
And then there was
an episode later
where somebody was
like it's a paradox.
And I was like they're
not going to have
Paradox walk by
in the background.
I was that fan on
Twitter like um,
excuse me, dear "Community"
is Paradox going to be by,
and it never happens.
CHRIS: Opportunity missed.
DANNY: But Magnitude,
all of them.
I think what's so
cool about our show is
that all the characters
are so specific that they
do really fit into this world.
CHRIS: Leonard.
DANNY: Oh, Leonard.
ALISON: Leonard.
And we love them,
and you guys end up
sort of writing stuff
for them or letting
them do stuff that speaks
true to them as well.
In the "Hot Lava" episode
we're all on Shirley island,
and the island's
going to go down,
and people are like
yelling confessions,
and Magnitude is like
I'm actually British,
because the actor that
plays Magnitude is British.
CHRIS: And those were really
Erik Charles Nielsen's
only pair of pants.
He couldn't get them dirty.
ALISON: Maybe.
Maybe.
MODERATOR: So my last question.
Not every show has
its own fan sponsored
Con, video games,
spin-off series.
What message do you
have for the fans
as we enter the home
stretch for season five?
CHRIS: Thank you?
DANNY: Thank you.
CHRIS: Thank you.
I mean honestly it's
no matter whether it's
a rerun of "The Big Bang
Theory" which gets like a 2.9
or a new episode
that gets a 5.1 there
is a little tiny army of people
who love the show as much as we
do who show up and watch
it live, don't you?
And no matter what
happens we still get,
or unless we'll see
what happens this week,
but we still get like the same
3 million people showing up
week in and week out.
And in this changing
TV landscape
to have people still showing up
and loving the show says a lot.
And it's the reason why this
little show that probably
should have died after
the end of season one
is halfway through
its fifth season.
So, yeah.
MODERATOR: Well,
we'll end with that.
Hashtag six seasons and a movie.
Thank you all for
stopping bye today.
So give them a
round of applause.
ALISON: Thank you.